hello everyone today we're talking about
neural networks and decision trees I
have Alexander Matic with me who is uh
maybe you introdu you want to introduce
yourself yeah I'm currently a student at
FAU so in Germany and most people don't
know me probably through uh for Yannick
for his Discord or I'm one of the people
who manage the paper discussions every
week and present more of the theoretical
papers usually so we came across this
paper uh all across social media I saw I
saw at one point and I'm like meh and
then I saw it like all over LinkedIn
being like neural networks are no longer
a black box we now know what's going on
uh I saw it on Twitter I saw it
essentially like it it like really got
some some push behind it as I said when
I first saw it it was like yeah this has
been known for a while so what does this
paper say in a general sense and has it
been known for while or is there
actually something in there okay so uh
basically what this network does is what
the paper does it shows how you can
basically take a neural network which is
a sequence of weights with non-linearism
between and then you can kind of each
virtually if you rewrite them by
effectively uh pulling out the right
slopes and merging them up into new
weights and that would give you
effectively this kind of structure it's
important to say this is only for if the
if the non-linearity is piecewise linear
for example a relu non-linearity
otherwise we we have an approximation
but this is an ex actually an exact
mapping that we're doing right here so
we just rewrite the neural network
somehow and then we get out what so we
get out such a tree and effectively you
can see these W hats here and these W
hats I think they're defined somewhere
yeah I think somewhere up here yeah
effectively just unroll the the piece by
slopes always from the layer above so
effectively we go and we draw the
different cases that happen through the
previous layer we draw them up into the
subsequent weights and that gives us
kind of this tree structure because we
of course get this unfolding of kind of
which path can we go in the neural
network and then the next net then the
next layer can kind of enhance in that
path and so on I think it's still a bit
unclear maybe to some people who are not
super familiar with this they might be
under like the general notion is a
neural network is a non-linear function
right therefore I wouldn't just be able
to represent it with a single even if
the W and the W hat are different right
I still at the bottom here I see you
know x times W something which is a
linear function so why all of a sudden I
have a neural network why do I arrive at
a bunch of linear functions this mostly
has to do with the fact that neural
networks intrinsically are just
compositions of these piecewise linear
functions for example there's been more
recent work I think here in the spline
theory of deep learning so it's more
recent work more recent than the paper
we're looking at now uh recent in a
sense of it was published after 2000.
okay
um this paper from I think 2018 and
there they make this very very explicit
where effectively they show that you can
unfold almost every Network into what is
called splines and you can think of
splines as kind of regions which then in
and of itself are affine linear so it's
a linear transform with some bias
against it and these deep neural
networks are just different regions all
of which have their own slope and slope
and bias if if we imagine a neural
network with relu non-linearities if we
imagine a point somewhere in the input
if we move that point like just a tiny
bit then we move it small enough so that
none it crosses none of these boundaries
a relu is essentially like like this so
it has like a boundary here where the
slope changes but if we move just small
enough that either the signal is in the
slope so it changes a bit in the slope
or it doesn't change at all because it's
in the Zero part so if we move just a
bit we don't change the relu activation
pattern and that essentially means since
all the functions are either linear or
piecewise linear but we don't switch the
piece that means that within such a relu
Cell It's essentially a linear function
I think that's what we see here at the
end of the decision tree the decision
tree essentially says with this
particular input which of these relu
cells am I in and at in inside of that
cell it's actually a linear function and
that's what's described here the neural
network in total is non-linear because
obviously we piece together super many
of these tiny relu cell regions and that
can make something that appears almost
like Smooth like because if we zoom out
then you know it's like a video game
where everything is made of triangles
but you zoom out and it kind of looks
round it kind of looks smooth the paper
shows you can rewrite the neural network
and you get something like this what
does it mean that's an entire different
question because
um so there are many different ways of
viewing such a conversion one is through
a practical lens another one is from a
lens of what does it help us to study
decision trees another one is how does
it help us to study neural networks
Pro position of studying decision trees
it doesn't really help us that much
because neural networks are inherently a
lot more
uh impenetrable than decision trees
really studying a neural network and
that helping us to figure out something
about decision trees is rather hard
additionally we have the problem that
decision trees fundament to the decision
Tree Learning algorithms we built are
they themselves don't map to neural
networks perfectly
what I mean by that is you can take a
decision tree like this thing here and
transform it into a neural network
however during the decision tree
training process what you usually do is
you take one of those effectively edges
and then you split it up into two lower
ones and for that you may need a new
neural network because the capacity of
the original one doesn't work out
anymore so from a perspective of taking
a neural network and then helping to
figure stuff out for decision trees
pretty hard on the other hand we can use
these decision trees to try and figure
out stuff about neural networks there's
a lot more promising but there is often
the case that to do the kind of analysis
you can do with the decision trees you
don't necessarily have to explicitly
build this tree like the supply theory
of deep learning paper which does lots
and lots of analysis so for example
there was a recent paper which
specifically looks at what batch Norm
actually does through this lens but they
don't need to build the explicit
decision tree because they are just
interested in this piecewise linearity
they're not necessarily interested in
how exactly this fits to the actual
neural network part or the actual tree
part and then last but not least we can
also analyze it through the view of
let's take an existing neural network
like a resnet and try and make it more
interpretable so that's where I also saw
a lot of the hype going on where because
well decision trees are more
interpretable the they you could
obviously go and take a resnet transform
it into a decision tree and have this
great interpretability but in practice
this doesn't really line up that well
and the reason is again kind of
connected to this idea of decision trees
making and being small and then
progressively growing when neural
networks are large and just basically
large enough to fit everything inside of
them that means that the actual size of
these neural network trees can become
rather gigantic the way we can do
analysis with a theoretical lens is by
studying something called the VC
Dimension or the bubnik chevonkins
dimension which effectively just tells
us
how many different points can Network
distinguish which of course for a
decision tree if you have a fully
balanced tree like this one would be 2
to the power of the depth of the tree
while for another Network it's a lot
harder to figure out because you have
all of these different architectures
what you can do though is we can go in
we can bound this and there's been like
lots of work in trying to figure out
bounds so for example the the best bound
I could find is from this paper from
2017 which provides nearly tight bounds
and specifically they provide this kind
of theorem for a lower bound meaning
what they basically shows there's some
Universal constant which has this
constraint so effectively the square of
it has to be less than number of Weights
you get a minimum amount of regions of
resolution for an internet from a neural
network of w so the number of Weights
times L which is the depth of the
network times the logarithm of w over L
and then you have this C constant in
here so it effectively means the number
of regions we have scales a little bit
more than linearly because we have this
W in the log and it stays a little bit
less than linearly with the number of
layers because we divide by L here so if
we now take this absolute lower bound so
what we can say is because we divide by
C here we can just set W equals to so we
can just set c squared equal to the
square root of w because that's kind of
the worst case scenario it gives us the
smallest bound and we can try to run
this so I have here this very trivial
neural network which has one hidden
layer we go from one to
one
so like this
or we can also look at something like 10
24 to look at something that would
happen for example a Transformer we have
this individual layers
if we if we run this we get for this
relatively small Network we get a depth
of this full decision tree of about 16.
if you would try to plot this so this is
not going to run for a very very long
time I mean 16 it doesn't seem that much
but this is essentially an exponent this
is an exponent so it is is a giant
number
if we have 2 to the power 16 again I'm
taking here that I'm routing the depth
Down 2 to the power 16 different regions
which is going to crush most algorithms
even if you could build such a decision
tree it would actually build one it
becomes a rather hard to reason about
them simply because the reason neural
networks are hard to interpret is not
necessarily because each individual
component is hard to interpret it's
because the emergent properties of
putting all of these things together and
these billions of parameters or millions
of parameters even together that makes
the problem hard
yes and I was I was so just to say that
this 16 depth three that's kind of the
best case scenario right that's that's
our bound on what what would be possible
uh in order for and transferring a
neural network to like what's the
minimum size of tree we need to even
represent that it could be the case that
it's more but that was my my impression
as well is when I look at a decision
tree I have sort of One path to go down
to make the decisions by right but if I
look at a classification problem it's
not always one path it's not just you
know is is the picture uh bright or dark
well okay if it's dark is it this and
this at some point you get the same
question right is the picture bright or
dark yes is there a small or a large
object in it let's say this question you
might want to ask whether it's light or
dark so you have like a matrix Right
light picture big object light picture
small object dark picture and so on and
but these are represented by two
different nodes in a decision tree no
matter how you how you structure it you
have to ask one question first and the
other question later and that means one
of these questions is necessarily going
to be represented by two different nodes
in the decision tree and so that just
for me looking at the decision tree I no
longer notice I no longer recognize or
the algorithm doesn't anymore tell me
that these two things are actually
related in some way so whereas in a
neural network I have internal
representation I have features or
weights that you know look at particular
features inside of these representations
one set of the neural network might look
at the lighting condition the other part
of the neural network may look at the
shape of something and they can work in
parallel in a decision tree it's one
after the other and therefore I'm no
longer the analysis gets way harder
because stuff in the decision tree
happens everywhere and it doesn't no
algorithm can tell me by the way these
things
represent the same feature it kind of
boils down to this fundamental tension
between having parametric and
non-parametric approaches
because so for the people who don't know
the the distinction here is effectively
a neural network is a fixed skeleton
with lots of blank spaces and the
objective of fitting to that fitting the
function in the neural network is
figuring out what should be put into its
blank spaces this is a parametric
approach because we have lots of
parameters
decision trees are non-parametric
approaches so what you do is you
effectively say we have this entire
family of different trees which not only
have parameters like this W but also you
have effectively the architecture which
gets optimized along the way and if you
have non-parametric approaches this
usually gives you way different
classifiers because in a parametric
approach because we have stuff like
gradients which make a lot of sense in
parametric approaches you can say
something like I don't necessarily want
an optimal split I just want some split
that effectively amounts to you go and
you take this W you just move it around
a little bit to go to go closer to a
good split the decision trees do it a
lot differently because decision trees
have to work with this gigantic family
of functions we now have to do optimal
splits at least to some optimality
constraint because you just randomly
kind of pull out decision trees and try
to figure out is this the right decision
tree you're never going to be able to
finish this is also why decision trees
tend to work well in stuff like tabular
data sets because you have relatively
few features which are very well defined
and you can compute statistics for them
which help you to figure out what would
be the perfect split for a specific
feature and which feature should I split
next while for something like an image
think about it you have an image which
is 224 by 224 by three uh by three RGB
channels the statistics you can get even
with a massive data set are not that
great especially since you have to
consider things like shifting around the
image a little bit to basically make the
statistics more robust
and that means you it's very hard to fit
a decision tree because statistics are
always bad
under Network performs way better
because it doesn't care about how well
it spitters it just does some split and
hopes for the best this means that a
neural network is by its nature going to
be less optimal
but it's also going to make some
progress even if they are only very bad
statistics where decision tree always
has some sense of optimality if you fit
it with something like cart because you
only do somewhat optimal splits
um of course at the cost of you have to
have some notion of what optimal means
so you have to know so you need those
statistics
yeah and
something like this algorithm
it is a decision tree so it's uh what
one would call a simple function in like
Mathematica speaks so decision trees are
effectively just nice representations of
simple functions but it's not really a
decision tree as it would be produced by
a decision tree algorithm and that's the
problem what makes them uninteroppable
because they just grow without bounds
these neural network trees so when we
look at let's get like back to the to
the paper at hand
um by the way this is still running
which which I like uh back to the paper
at hand is this is the proof sound
the proof that neural networks are
decision trees right it's like it is it
is absolutely sound it's not wrong all
good is it new or unknown
no so there are multiple things to that
one is there are already papers in the
past which did that so for example this
paper I think is from 1999
yep November 1999. uh they also showed
like
um either for extraction of decision
trees from artificial networks so this
is known and it's also one of those
things that oftentimes just happens to
plop out as a corollary so there are
very few people who go and explicitly
write this proof down because it's kind
of a natural thing that occurs if you
have some algorithm which splits the
world up into kind of classification
polygons or Simplex simplices or affine
regions which for example this paper
does then getting this decision tree
form is expected as a correlator it just
plops out passively so this paper here
for example the supply theory of deep
learning paper could easily just say
well yeah the decision of which spline
we are in is made hierarchically in the
form of a decision tree so it would be a
one sentence and that just plops out the
same would be true for many of these
theoretical proofs where first of all
very rarely do you actually need this
decision tree kind of realized but
oftentimes the proof behind it that for
example abuses the fact that we have
have this realu Max function which
effectively tells us to go either to the
left where you have the zero region or
to the right where we have new values
that is often just there you don't need
to do any more to get the actual
decision tree out I also I know this
from
um because I used to work quite a bit in
the field of adversarial examples and
there I think it it was made oftentimes
quite quite explicit to some degree
because obviously people as long as
stuff is linear you could have some some
kind of bounds on how worse it can get
but then as soon as it's non-linear uh
it gets a bit more tricky and you've
also shown me before like a paper on
verification of neural networks which is
exactly right uh sort of in this area
where people are trying to say well how
bad can it get and they use the fact
that also there we have these
essentially these these cells of
linearity so one of the problems that's
also what this veloplex algorithm the
idea is that you can view this Max
operation effectively as splitting
everything up into a Simplex then you
can make arguments about with something
like an smt solver you can try to make
arguments okay what happens inside the
Simplex or basically what can happen
inside the neural network and you can do
that to guarantee some safety guarantee
that you have some safety guarantees but
even this algorithm gets crushed at
scale and the scale as we've seen here I
think it's still running
yeah it explodes rather quickly
so and they of course don't explicitly
build this but yeah this this idea of
neural networks mapping well to decision
trees kind of boils down to the fact
that a feed forward network is specially
just a gigantic graph you can just take
every you can effectively compute the
spanning tree of that graph and that
gives you a decision tree at least in
the case of a relu and that's basically
also what this paper does we compute the
spanning tree by Computing these W hats
and these W hats take the slope from the
appropriate slope from the previous
layer and come and build up the
appropriate W hats
so maybe for for people so the if you we
can just go to these formulas with one
of the A's because that's kind of the
crucial part of the math right here is
these a vectors uh and you have to like
it still seems a bit like magic we have
like the non-linear composition of
function and then all of a sudden
we we have these a vectors and somehow
now all is linear but one has to
remember that so on the bottom here we
have the non-linearity that not
essentially what I do is I take the
signal that comes through the network at
and I look at the signal at the
non-linearity and there I say well where
is the signal such that the relu is
active and where is the signal such that
the relu is inactive and it just replace
that by a vector of ones and zeros or or
the the slopes and zeros right but these
these vectors are dependent on the
signal and that's why the they're gonna
look different if the input is different
and that that's why it's a linear
function for a given input in a given
very tiny Circle right so that's I think
that's the connection now the paper also
has some experimental result and there
is a a small claim uh but there is a
claim that the decision tree
representation might be advantageous in
a computational manner so they have a
table one comparing the decision tree
and the neural networks for the same
function in terms of their computational
complexity so it turns out the decision
trees have more parameters which is
which is uh odd for a non-parametric
function but I guess they're not learned
parameters
yet
the
neural networks use more multiplications
and additions than the decision tree
what do we make of that well computation
often is not the same as computation
because you may have more
multiplications or additions but they
may be in a forum which is just nicer
for
for you to work with so for example if
we look at the trees or like here or
let's go back up to the this kind of
prototypical tree where effectively we
have these these multiplications with
the with this x0 input what happens is
that we do have fewer multiplications
using that structure because effectively
we abuse the fact that we don't have to
compute the entire Matrix we only have
to compute the part which is actually
going to be relevant for us later on
that of course reduces the number of
multiplications but on the other hand we
now have this spreading out we have more
decisions in here and less
multiplications and depending how your
how your Hardware ends up it might be
that basically paying for more
computation and having less decisions is
better that's why training a decision
Tree on a CPU makes more sense than
training it on a GPU on the other hand
there are also approaches which take
decision trees and basically compile
them into what's effectively binary
matrix multiplication these algorithms
tend to of course for inference in that
case but these algorithms tend to be a
lot faster simply because even though
you do more addition and multiplication
and stuff like that you end up having so
much parallelism that this what is it uh
a factor of four roughly
is not that meaningful or it's closer to
free
well on the left it's eight but
it's 2 versus 16.
well in in any case but but that's
that's the point right if if one were to
actually implement the decision Tree on
like a GPU one would actually regain all
of these multiplications and additions
because it just makes more sense to put
the binary Vector there with a lot of
zeros and then multiply all of these
zeros
instead of trying to mask out stuff and
uh because the GPU can just parallelize
so hard
yeah it's supposed to that gpus don't
tend to do well with lots of decision
making and lots of spiracy because just
of the way they are designed they're
designed to do large operations on a lot
of data very basically monotonically
they just do have a large matrix
multiplication with very little decision
making every single one of these
thousands of career cores effectively
does exactly the same thing
and that then gives you kind of this
boost because there are thousands of
cores doing very simple very repetitive
actions and
if you have more decision making
more decision making in there that just
makes it slower I I think I interviewed
uh near shavit of neural magic and
effectively they're they're doing
something very similar where they say
okay what we do is we take like a bird
or something like this we prune it very
in a special way such that the rest is
something we can infer on CPU really
well uh which is essentially like very
similar to to this paper right here so
the idea of sort of pruning it down and
all of a sudden you may end up with
something that sparse requires more if
else but then is very much suited to a
CPU if we think about maybe the last
question for today if we think about
okay this this this paper is is it's
certainly correct and all but we think
it has it has been known or it's it's I
I don't like the word trivial uh because
nothing like I I used to hate that as a
student because to me nothing ever was
super driven and it's even if it's
trivial it's good that it's written down
explicitly somewhere right you can point
to a place out here but in a sense it is
like something that a lot of people have
just kind of done on the side because it
it is fairly like natural a natural
outcome of working with these these
systems but if we look at a bit beyond
that and say is there a a way in which
decision trees can kind of make a bit of
a comeback in today's world of deep
learning maybe not as a substitute but
as an augmentation of neural networks
can we like what kind of properties does
a problem need to have such that
a combination of something like decision
tree algorithms like the Symmetry
learning algorithms and neural networks
are the best
so this Industries really like to have
these very very well-defined statistics
because that helps to do their splits
effectively learn neural networks scale
with gradients so if you can't get
gradients if you have a hard time and
they also scale with size simply because
as you've seen here you just get more
possible
uh more representational power so it's
just better you can effectively simulate
a small decision tree inside a large
enough neural network but just setting
everything else for zero around it the
trick that makes decision trees work
well is if you have these statistics
so that's why decision trees work
incredibly well on something like
tabular data like you can also tabular
like deep learning but that's probably
like you're going to go you're going to
do research you're going to do probably
a PhD and then out plops a project which
may or may not be competitive on tabular
data but on the other hand I can just
use XJ boost and get great results right
now what you would want to do to get
decision trees to work well is you would
want to take these very very high
Dimensions very very information sparse
for example images and transported into
like a lower dimensional space where you
can then get the statistics so for
example if we have a two-stage approach
where you have main neural networks
inferring different features of the same
thing so you first try to classify
whether it's a cat or a dog then you try
to classify I don't know its size or
whatever and you put them all down then
you can start doing a decision Tree
Learning and the decision tree is
probably going to be a lot more
performance simply because you get this
smaller size through the fact that the
neural net that the decision tree is
much more optimal in how it uses its
splits and capacity it seems like the
current wave of self-supervised learning
might actually be a good candidate to
build something like this on top because
the self-supervised algorithm they tend
they tend to sort of extract many
different kinds of features whereas like
if I pre-train a classifier on imagenet
let's say that classifier is going to be
attuned to very few features for the
bunch of classes it needs to classify
but just from what I can observe the
self-supervised approaches they they
just tend to kind of get this Rich
representation out of images and we see
that if you know we look at at anything
that uses a vqan encoder nowadays which
is almost all of the AI art projects so
they're they're so rich such a rich
representation so this this could be
especially maybe the quantized stuff
could be like a very fertile ground to
then put like decision trees random
Forest whatever on top of that
yeah cool all right I think that's
that's about the paper is kind of really
short it's I guess four four or five
pages uh if you if you if you you know
it is it is very
like I think it's very approachable so
um you know if you've never heard of any
sort of equivalence like this or or any
math in this area it's very helpful I
think to actually look at it and just
see how it's done
um might give you a bit of an insight
and yeah Alexandra thank you so much for
being here it was a pleasure yeah
thank you for having me
cool and everyone if you want to hear
more rants of Alexander and myself we
have discussions on Discord almost every
Saturday evening or well in at least
evening in Europe right cool bye
everyone
bye
[Music]